key
e
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci je m'appelle don
gates ans j'ai fondé le studio superbe
en 2011 avec gaël et le kick festival
avec gilles grand dam de ceux qui me
côtoient
j'aime le beatbox ce n'est pas tellement
le fait que j'aime le beat box qui est
le problème c'est le fait que je suis
plutôt mauvais gars me prédestinait à
faire ce que je fais aujourd'hui
mais deux rencontres ont changé ma vie
là se guérir sun le jeune et beau
norvégien que vous venez de voir et la
deuxième est la première est une petite
annonce pour des cours de batterie que
je vais suivre pendant quelques mois
mais plutôt réfractaire aux méthodes et
résistant j'ai préféré continuer
l'apprentissage dans mon grenier seul je
suis le troisième enfant d'une fratrie
de quatre
tout sportif de haut niveau l'enfant
qu'on appelle l'enfant du milieu le
sport en question c'est le volley ball
j'occupe la place du passeur ce qu'ils
soient toutes les balles et les
redistribue aux autres ils placent de
tempo une place de riscle une place au
milieu
mais dans cette compétition dans ce
sport ou qui se rêve en grand
je suis plutôt le personnage de gauche
sur cette image j'ai donc cherché une
parade pour fuir il contraintes qu'il
paraissait trop grande a dépassé je joue
toujours dans mon grenier seul et j'ai
la chance de rejoindre un groupe de
musique qui s'appelle fait que sabine
d'eau
trois jours avant un concert parce que
le batteur faisait faux rebond
l'histoire a duré une dizaine d'années
nous avons sorti trois albums fait de
nombreuses tournées jouer des premières
parties avant des groupes assez
prestigieux comme les dandy warhols nada
surf placebo j ai rencontré gaël
bassiste ingénieurs et loïc guitariste
gaël avec qui j'ai donc fondé superbe en
2011 à nouveau dans ce projet j'occupe
une place plutôt au milieu rythmique
tempo mais celui qu'on voit jamais j'ai
fait des études en psychologie et j'ai
entamé un travail personnel je me suis
posé là cette fois au milieu de mon
existence
j'ai réfléchi au fonctionnement de mon
désir j ai découvert que les contraintes
les plus difficiles à dépasser sont
souvent nous parce qu'elles sont
intimement liée au désir justement la
question être à l écoute de soi c'est
inscrit dans des rythmes le rythme de la
pensée
le rythme des séances chez le psy le
rythme des rêves le rythme de
l'inconscient le rythme du corps qui
s'exprime bien souvent malgré nous j'ai
lu notamment françoise dolto m'a
beaucoup aidé beaucoup inspiré je me
suis intéressé à l'enfance
et savez-vous paradoxalement les
premières expériences sonores se font à
travers la peau qu'on appelle aussi plus
grands organes du corps en effet les
sons et plus particulièrement la voix de
la mère fait vibrer le liquide
amniotique dans lequel nous baignons
tous notre corps vibre avant que nous
entendions avant que l'oreille ne soit
prête
il est intéressant de savoir aussi que
nous faisons très tôt l'expérience de la
musique
nous plongeons dans le langage par sa
musicalité les modulations vocal
ressemble à une musique et comprendre
les émotions de l'autre se trouve bien
en-deça du sens véhiculée par la langue
cette année
ans ne nous quittera jamais mais nous
n'y prêtons guère attention j'ai oublié
de préciser toutes les images d'archivés
sont d'époque
je me suis donc ouvert au champ de la
pensée
j'ai réfléchi à la musique notamment et
fort de mon expérience de sportif et de
batteur plus particulièrement en rythme
et suis arrivé à cette conclusion
c'est pas la fin de la conférence
à commencer par le cor qui composait de
nombreux rythme quand quelques exemples
le battement de coeur nous le coeur bat
entre 60 et 100 fois par minute environ
qui présente 100 mille fois par jour
donc cerveau des ondes voyage à des
rythmes différents des vitesses
différentes des fréquences différentes
d'art à 4,6 secondes pour les plus
lentes et de 12 à 16 6 secondes pour les
plus rapides nous respirons douze à dix
huit fois par minute qui veut dire 26
mille fois par jour environ 700 millions
de fois au cours d'une vie les cycles du
sommeil sont en moyenne de 90 minutes
ils sont composés de trois types de
sommeil le sommeil lent et léger le
sommeil lent et profond pendant lequel
nous récupérons et le sommeil paradoxal
pendant lequel nous rêvons nous clignant
des yeux environ 20 fois par minute 28
mille fois par jour 10 millions de fois
par an nous déglutit sont deux fois par
minute ce qui représente quand même un
litre et demi de sa vive par jour
les cheveux ouais
très facile les cheveux ne pousse pas de
manière continue mais par cycle décide
de 2 à 4 ans pour les femmes
donc pour les hommes et de 4 à 7 ans
pour les femmes et les cheveux poussent
environ 2,5 mm à 2 cm par mois environ
il se fait 2 trillions de division
cellulaire dans le corps par jour
environ 2 milliards de milliards du coup
les rythmes des séquences de l'adn le
rythme d'une ville en comparaison aux
rythmes de la nature
le rythme des saisons le rythme du jour
et de la nuit
la semaine du mois de notre horloge
biologique
je pourrais vous inciter à l'infini le
cycle des civilisations cycle en
économie les cycles de l'évolution le
rythme en architecture le rythme dans la
peinture le rythme dans l'écriture toute
forme de vie toutes formes de création
comporte en son sein un rythme et ce
rythme on assure une cohérence en
donnant une forme à son déroulement
la musica
avi vraiment elle est
elle a validé des sensations des
émotions elle a fait office de battement
créateurs pour moi de cohérence elle m'a
donné confiance
le rythme auquel je suis sensible m'a
amené à mon métier d'aujourd'hui quand
je découvre là se guérit sonne le jeune
et beau norvégien que vous avez vu au
début de la conférence
je comprends qu'il n'y a pas qu'une
seule façon pratique et le beatbox qu'on
peut en inventer d'autres et surtout on
peut en faire profiter les autres
nous créons avec gaël en 2009 notre
premier projet nappé de musique au maton
une boîte automatique à fabriquer du
beatbox avec votre sont votre image que
vous enregistrez à l'intérieur et les
sept personnes qui sont passés avant
vous une espèce de beatbox collectif que
vous pouvez consulter en sortant de la
boîte et au casque via l'écran écouter
le résultat pour ce bien un ticket avec
un code et ce code vous servez à
retrouver votre séquence sur internet un
clip vidéo de mise en situation
[Musique]
lors de notre première diffusion
publique en 2010 ont eu beau tannique
ça c'est le genre par avance
génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avons découvert le plaisir observé les
gens et fort de ces expériences nous
avons décidé de poursuivre
[Musique]
donc nous avons poussé d'autres
cherchent ils nous sommes allé un peu
plus loin
nous avions envie de laisser aux gens
l'opportunité d'organiser les sont eux
mêmes on nous avons créé une application
qui associe géométrie et musique en
utilisant la géométrie on permet aux
gens de créer des rythmes parfois très
complexes
en tout intuition et de manière visuelle
j'imagine que vous êtes impatients que
je vous fascine des mois alors je vous
la fais non je rigole c'était prévu boum
j'enregistre un son je choisis une forme
le cercle est sélectionné je valide mons
on va être lu sur chaque à arette bon de
la forme géométrique
ici en l'occurrence auxerre ne comporte
qu'une seule je peux lire le sont de
manière différente à l'envers mot
ralenti ou ne rien mettre c'est à dire
un silence regardez celui ci je peux
changer la taille en réduisant la taille
j'accélère électeurs home de manière
proportionnelle aux trains deuxième
symptôme part je lui assigne un triangle
triangle va structurer le rythme en
trois temps en lisant vos abdos jamais
changé je choisis le carré
et dernière forme l'hexagone
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais c'est un simple à farid
complexe fait en quelques secondes et
nous avons eu la bonne idée dit si
délicieuse idée bien qu une fonction
aléatoire jeu active et je vous préviens
c'est totalement risque est évidemment
sans fin je m'arrêter là nous avons
ensuite décomposer le principe on fait
une installation avec laquelle les gens
peuvent créer du rythme de manière
collective dans l'espace les formes sont
liés nouveau l'univers est cohérent et
le sait la géométrie qui structure
l'ensemble des sons ensuite nous sommes
allés encore un peu plus loin et nous y
avons intégré à un principe harmonique
nous avons créé une chorale un
dispositif de chorales interactive dans
laquelle vous êtes à la fois le chef
d'orchestre et toutes les voix de la
chorale
j'ai un peu laissé jamais gagné le chat
qui des synchros la havane il vient d'en
c'est important dans une chorale il faut
que tout le monde suive
on n'a qu'un petit port bon c'est un guy
fin ça c'est enfin aussi donc pas ça à
ses hommes une petite vidéo mise en
situation
l'installation de contenus comme les
autres tapie
un enregistrement images en fait avant
qui va être utilisé comme matière pour l
ensemble de la chorale donc les voir
oh
ensuite un capteur est dissimulée dans
le bon mot de la baguette du chef
d'orchestre et permet
pénalisé les mouvements que vous faites
les noms de la musique a créé en
fonction à l'ecoute les mouvements que
vous exécutez
eux se projette une forme
d'aboutissement permettre à l'autre de
faire l'expérience de la musique comme
j'ai pu la faire plutôt dans ma vie ce
ming c'est une rencontre avec l'intimité
est une invitation à ce qu'elles
s'expriment dans tout intuition ces
lycées permettre à l'émotion de
s'exprimer dans le rythme du mouvement
et d'en libérer une forme de spontanéité
des gens ils découvrent leur propre
rythme leur propre rapport au temps leur
propre musique déplacer des contraintes
revient à changer de tribun une
résolution pourrait alors consisté à
changer de contraintes ont créé
transformer déplacer une sorte de
redistribution qui offrirait à celui qui
la vit avec synchronisation une forme
d'harmonie
le rythme est une adresse par et pour le
vivant un échange permanent dans lequel
nous avons tous à prendre place à
prendre forme
je vous laisserai avec cette phrase
patrick sutter l'expérience du rythme
correspondrait à une véritable genèse
qui n'équivaudrait pas seulement à une
découverte du corps mais encore un
avènement de l'être au monde
je vous remercie
key
[Musique]